donald trump is involved in a litany of
lawsuits and investigations between
allegations of election interference
business fraud and inciting a mob it can
be difficult to keep them all straight
so we spoke with forbes staff writer
zach everson to break down a few of the
biggest cases against trump and what
they mean for the former president
first the new york attorney general's
investigation
the office of new york attorney general
leticia james is looking into the
property evaluations that donald trump's
provided over the years in some
instances they're looking into whether
he has inflated them when it suits him
and in other instances if he's lowered
them when it suits him as well such as
the tax filings it is a civil
investigation it is not something that
could end up in criminal charges there
are two other investigations in
different jurisdictions that are also
looking into this issue the manhattan
d.a and the westchester county the new
york ag one is the one we which we know
the most about
largely because the former president is
not complying with subpoenas so the
attorney general's office has had to
repeatedly go to court to try to get
them to do so most recently leticia
james asked the judge to hold the former
president in contempt and find him ten
thousand dollars a day until he does
comply
the manhattan district attorney's office
is investigating trump in the trump
organization for allegedly inflating the
value of properties on financial
statements this investigation is a
criminal one
recently however a couple of lead
prosecutors stepped away concerned that
the new district attorney alvin bragg
was not going to be prosecuting the
former president bragg issued a press
release recently however saying that the
investigation was still continuing
there's also an investigation in
westchester county where one of his
properties is and that has been pretty
quiet we just know that investigation is
happening but we haven't had any details
the office won't respond to requests for
comment and if they do have any findings
that are that are egregious you know at
the end of the day it could certainly
take a lot of money from them if there
is a civil fine but is it going to be
substantial enough to say knock them off
a billionaire's list probably not you
know you could certainly say they'd be
reputational damage but i think at this
point
you already have your opinion on donald
trump
next election fraud damage claims
a delaware county pennsylvania elections
official he oversees the voting machines
in the warehouse is suing for defamation
asking for at least fifty thousand
dollars claiming that accusations that
he tampered with the vote has impacted
his ability to do his job he's suing
trump along with some other people
involved in the campaign notably jenna
ellis and rudy giuliani
trump's attorneys have filed a
preliminary objection to the case and
the the plaintiffs are still moving
forward they're trying to get discovery
started and that is also being argued
about as well
there was a lot of um
residual damage to some people with
these election fraud claims you know
you're seeing the the overall result was
obviously
trump's out of office the election
results stood as they should have but
you know all those claims in throwing of
that mud it stuck to some people like
people who are not usually in the news
but people who work for elections boards
people who work for voting boards and
their reputation is harm and then you
know for a brief period of time a lot of
these people just got slammed online all
sorts of online abuse because they were
accused of throwing the election in
favor of joe biden and they were in
cahoots with the big state and i mean
honestly these are just people going
about in this case doing his warehouse
job
and finally cases related to january 6th
the riot at the capitol on january 6 has
led to several cases and investigations
regarding former president trump most
notably there's the house select
committee on january 6 which is
researching the causes of the event
while the committee's final result is
set to be a report on the way to that
report it has been referring some cases
to the justice department recently the
house referred two allies of former
president trump peter navarro and dan
scavino to the justice department for
defying congressional subpoenas
former president trump also faces
several lawsuits from police officers
over the january six riots the police
officers are both with the capitol
police and the metro police of dc and
they're alleging that trump inflamed
encouraged incited directed aided and
abedded the rioters who assaulted them
additionally there are two suits that
members of congress have filed against
the former president one is a group of
legislators led by karen bass the other
is representative eric swalwell and they
are alleging that there was a conspiracy
to incite a mob violating civil rights
laws most notably the ku klux klan act
of 1867 which was passed in hopes of
keeping the clan from preventing
legislators from doing their official
duties
trump's doing what trump does he is
fighting all of the allegations and
doing everything he can to slow up the
judicial process
taking his time fighting against
subpoenas and just in general not
cooperating which he doesn't really have
to he's using legal avenues to to fight
them this case this investigation is
easily the most consequential for donald
trump as you know an investigation to
trying to overturn election results
probably should be
there's probably not going to be much
impact on his businesses but this this
could potentially result in criminal
charges again that would be a long way
off if it happens at all but the general
six committee already has referred some
people over to the department of justice
[Music]